good evening mr. Gao I feel that the
leave campaign is spreading project lies
yes project lies with no concrete
evidence on what will happen to the
economy if we watch to leave I think I
feel your campaign is more to do with a
bunch of politicians wanting to further
their own political careers
tell me mr. Gao why should we trust you
well John I think that you should trust
the case that I'm making rather than any
individual politician this debate is far
bigger than the fate of any individual
politician it's about all of us in this
room and all of us at home it's about
the sort of country that we want to see
it appears to me that you're asking
people to vote for a divorce and sort
the financial settlement out afterwards
and that makes no sense to me you know
there's lots of people who go through
divorces and the last thing I want to do
is try and sort the money out afterwards
you negotiate before and without having
a plan in place and having put the
effort into that plan it makes no sense
to me and with all due respect mr. Gove
it appears to me that it's almost like a
First World War general you've got
you're waving the flag you're saying
over the top men but you have no idea
what's on the frontline or what the
casualty rate will be in the conflicts
to come well it's certainly an arresting
image the First World War image but
ultimately what I'm putting my faith in
is the ingenuity the creativity and the
strength of the British people many of
those who are arguing that we should
remain are trying to frighten you by
saying that it would be impossible for
Britain to succeed they're saying that
Britain is too small too poor and we're
all too stupid to be able to succeed on
the outside I comprehensively reject
that I think it's this pointing to see
the leave campaign use its divisive
tactics on the issue of immigration one
of the greatest things in our society is
multiculturalism do you regret that
leave campaign has been focusing on the
so-called problems of immigration well
Sam I agree with you I think one of the
great things about Britain
is that it's a hugely successful
multicultural multi-ethnic multiracial
society that's a really good thing on
one of the ways in which we've built
that success is that in the past we've
been able to control migration so it's
Anna benefits of everyone I'd like to
see migration continue in the future but
I'd like to see it controlled and the
only way that we can control migration
indeed the only way that we can be truly
fair to everyone who wants to come here
is to leave the European Union
I find the Scottish independence
referendum to be a really nasty and
divisive and so if the rest of the UK
votes to leave the EU but the majority
of people in Scotland remain there's
another Scottish referendum inevitable
and the breakup of the Union no I don't
think it is a majority of people in
Scotland are against a second referendum
and a majority of people in Scotland are
against independence and I didn't think
if the people of the United Kingdom
votes to leave one union that the people
of Scotland will vote to leave another